hi welcome to the reason live stream I
am Zach Weissmuller and I'm joined today
by Two Gentlemen who invested a lot of
time and energy and in some cases money
into the topic of artificial
intelligence which is what we're talking
about today specifically whether or not
it poses such grave danger that all work
on large language models like chat GPT
should be paused until we figure out
what the hell is going on
yon talin is a computer programmer and
Tech investor who was part of the team
that developed the software for Skype
and old Millennials like me also owe him
a bed of gratitude for making college
dorm file sharing that much easier since
before Skype he helped create Kaza if
you know you know Tallinn is an investor
in several artificial intelligence
Ventures including an early investment
in Google's Deep Mind and later in the
AI company anthropic where he's also on
the board of directors and also very
relevant to this conversation he is a
co-founder of the future of Life
Institute which organized an open letter
calling for an immediate pause on giant
AI experiments a letter that was signed
by the likes of Apple's Steve Wozniak
Elon Musk and more than 27 000 other
people Jan thank you very much for
joining us
thank you so much for having me
important important collection I'm not a
director of anthropic although I am a
board Observer deliberately okay thank
you
Observer okay and um Robin Hansen is an
associate professor of Economics at
Georgetown University and research
associate at the future of humanity
Institute at Oxford he's the author of
books like the elephant in the brain and
particularly relevant to this
conversation the age of M which lays out
in great detail one possible AI
dominated future he's also made
regularly about AI at his popular blog
overcoming bias where recently argued
that most AI fear is future fear Robin
thank you very much for joining us great
to be here looking forward
let's open with a discussion of the
letter which has generated a fair amount
of conversation media coverage and
possibly even LED with the heads of all
the major AI companies
this letter definitely caught my
attention
um going into this I'll admit that my
inclination is to be suspicious of both
doomsday predictions and definitely
suspicious of calls for preemptive
regulation of emerging technology which
we know can cause serious unseen damage
uh in Innovation That Never Comes to be
but
the fact that a lot of high-profile
people in the field
um have signed this letter combined with
some recent public statements from
insiders at some of the companies which
we can play a little bit later
has set up it's set off some alarm Bells
um which is why I'm really grateful to
have you both here to make your cases so
let's first look at the bolded demand in
this letter which says we call on all AI
labs to immediately pause for at least
six months the training of AI systems
more powerful than gpt4 so Jan could you
make the case for why this kind of pause
is necessary
sure so to give you a bigger a bit of a
backstory
um like
in the beginning of March I wrote the
memo uh telegrams distributed
with a lot of people who are concerned
about AI as well as people who are
working at AI labs and I claimed that in
my subjective assessment every 10 exync
uh every kind of order a magnitude of
compute that's being thrown at this
black box experiments that are
unsupervised and have like massive
that already have like massive compute
that is being thrown at them every
connection causes roughly like my my
ninety percent uh
St 90 confidence range is one percent to
fifty percent existential risk uh to
humanity and I uh a asked for people to
push back on that saying that you're
crazy uh there is like uh no way like
that and here's why and uh and like
absent that I I said that we should be a
asking uh for people in the labs uh what
do they think uh the
the probability of complete destruction
of the planet is as a result of the
experiments that they're doing uh and
drawing parallels to the report the
first existential risk report that this
planet produced was called report delay
602 by Manhattan Project scientists who
basically faced a similar situation
where they wasn't weren't sure if their
work will with the planet can withstand
our work if the planet can
can survive the first nuclear detonation
so they did their homework the data
calculation
so I guess I thought that it was it's
time for the for the people working on
this uh unparalleled systems to do
similar homework or at least gives the
give the subjective assessment
and the other thing uh that I uh said
that if
that we should be asking for is uh
because as I say I can read it
advocating for both voluntary and
government enforced moratoriums on such
scaling experiments until there's clear
understanding of the existential risk
they pause and I
so that basically what's happened
happened on the back end at the same
time uh articles by Esther Klein and you
will Harare came out uh also expressing
kind of uh sort of unease about what is
happening uh with AI so at uh was like
on this
sometime in the March it was like 21st
March or something like that we had like
future Life Institute called and we
started discussing this situation and
somebody proposed that wait a minute we
we have uh
experience with open letters we have the
uh I know
back end
Etc we have done letters with up to like
thousand participants and and thought
that okay like let's let's just like
take the temperature of the of the
situation uh and sort of like create
common knowledge so
in some ways the goal with meta with the
letter was like more like a meta goal uh
less about uh it was less about the
pause much less about the six months
post the letter said uh at least six
months pause but it was basically
the goal was to create
common knowledge in a way that like
people have something to point to and
say that look we are concerned and we
see that other people are also concerned
let's do something about it
what is your reaction to that uh Robin
the the both the letter and Jan's
explanation of it being kind of a call
to I guess rally some awareness as to
the potential risks of AI and also
create this sort of common rallying
point for people to start talking about
about this issue
foreign
I agree that it's not that plausible
that in fact we would Implement such a
pause soon especially through's
legislation or something but that this
is can be seen as a political trial
balloon that's often done in many
contexts you raise a flag and you see
who salutes basically so I I believe
that yes uh some people are concerned
many people are concerned and this is a
you know attempt to show that many
people are concerned but it's not just
showing concern it's showing concern in
a particular direction it's it's
indicating that many people might be
willing two more strongly regulate or
you know coordinate privately through
something as a substitute for regulation
in this direction so you know that's
what they're trying to do here is to get
more people to perceive that more of us
are okay with
something like regulating this because
of particular concerns they have so you
know my issues would be is this the sort
of thing now that's worth doing that
level of coordination or regulation uh
that would be the key question that is
this is a good thing to do if in fact we
are near the time when it would be a
good idea to coordinate in such a way
and that this would be a good first step
in that direction but if you think this
is too early
and we might go too far too fast then
this would be a bad idea
so that is the fundamental question that
we're here to discuss today and I would
say that the letter I I at least I'm
assuming that the letter has played a
role in this because there there has
been a new stepped up effort or some
momentum to push AI regulation uh we've
got this meeting that happened last week
where the CEOs of the major AI companies
were summoned to the White House to talk
it out with Kamala Harris uh there's
apparently uh legislation underway that
Chuck Schumer is laying the groundwork
for according to some reporting from
axios there's four pillars to this the
identification of who trained the
algorithm and who its intended audience
is is one of the steps the disclosure of
the data source for training the AI and
explanation for how it arrives at its
responses so that's kind of in response
to the the black box idea that Jan was
Raising earlier and transparent and
strong ethical boundaries so and and
also we've got uh you know on the heels
of that meeting and I'm gonna have Adam
play this clip in a second is Sam Altman
the CEO of open AI which is kind of
viewed as the industry leader at this
this point in terms of large language
models or you know chat Bots
um has said he welcomes regulation so
let's play that clip of uh Sam Altman
and then I'd like to get Robin's
reaction uh as a Critic of preemptive
regulation
our mission is to figure out how to
build these Advanced AI systems and
deploy them into society for maximum
benefit and that requires partnership
with government and regulation that
companies can do a lot and we talked
about this yesterday to get that started
but long term we will need governments
our government governments around the
world uh to act and to put regulation in
place and standards in place that make
sure that we get as much of the good as
possible of these from these
Technologies and minimize the downsides
longer term as these systems become
really really powerful I do think we
will need some sort of international
Authority that is that is looking at the
people building the most powerful
systems and making sure that we are
running evaluations for safety getting
extra
so what what do you think of what Sam
Altman is saying there Robin
well he's trying to be a good you know
corporate Citizen and saying that I'm
not you know regulation isn't crazy and
I guess what we want to support it and
as you as you probably know often
industry leaders are fine with
regulation that creates a barrier to
entry to competitors so it's not not
strange that industry leaders might be
welcoming in regulation but you know our
fundamental question here has to be uh
is this the time to do regulation and if
we were going to do some sort of
Regulation what sort would be a good
idea uh as you know some kinds of
Regulation can just be heavy-handed and
really shut down Innovation and so I
would say if we're going to do anything
in the direction of Regulation let's
talk about what would be robust gentle
even Market based sorts of Regulation
that might address some of the concerns
uh but not hinder the rest of the
industry
what just to follow up there what what
are your major concerns with what
non-careful regulation
might do in terms of our the development
of this technology could you just lay
out you know some of your some of your
fears of AI regulation
well Humanity in the last century uh
basically shut down nuclear energy
industry pretty effectively and we
basically said no we didn't want to go
there with modest exceptions uh more
recently we basically shut down genetic
engineering and said no we didn't want
to go there
uh we may just see AI that way and want
to shut it down that is I I some people
say that this we really couldn't
regulate this that would be infeasible
is too spread out and too too many
strong interests look at the past I'd
say it is possible to strongly regulate
some Industries and there is strong
public opinion uh in support of being
wary of AI and holding it back so I fear
the worst case of really just shutting
down the whole industry and really
foregoing enormous potential
what do you think about that Jan um the
the nuclear energy example is an
interesting one because we've seen that
we've seen the the consequences of that
in in real time uh as of late where now
there's you know increasing concern
about carbon emissions and nuclear
energy is one of the low carbon
potentially abundant sources of energy
but the kind of advancement with stifled
and now we're stuck you know decades
behind where we might have otherwise
been if there hadn't been what might be
characterized as a little bit of a panic
around regulating it and making the
barriers too high
um how do does thinking about that
problem work into your Calculus and
putting out a public call for pausing AI
at this appointment development
I think this is like based on like uh
unfortunately the common misconception
of the letter the letter was like very
very very explicit that this is not
about posing the AI research okay it was
very particular that this is about
posing the large KLA experiments now now
are uh kind of reaching hundreds of
millions of dollars and I understand
based on some
unclear or like uh
not super reliable sources uh the next
GPT 5 is starting gt55 training will
start like later this year
and and probably will be
yeah I don't know hundreds of millions
could possibly like a billion dollars uh
and important that they are
like super super simple they are
experiments that are sort of like I call
them summoning of AI because uh they are
something like 200 lines of code uh and
then like enormous amount of data and
they are unsupervised the thing will be
run for months uh without humans
checking what's happening and then they
stopped then they do the checkpoint that
they called and that then they see what
this thing is capable and then they can
resume or or stop uh now the problem is
that
with with these experiments uh they are
producing uncontrollable Minds uh the
yeah that's why I call it someone and
tame uh Paradigm of AI uh the latest
like llms how they work is that you
summoned this mind uh from the Mind
space using your data and a lot of
compute a lot of money and then you try
to tame it using things like uh
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback parallel HF Etc so I think it's
and like very importantly the Insiders
do think that then they can they are
taking some existential risk of the
planet uh during those large-scale
experiments so I think
one reason for some kind of pause or
some kind of timeout is that that's
informed the planet that their lives are
being risked now by the Insiders the
Insiders agree that like I have not met
with anyone right now in this lab so
says that sure the risk is less than one
percent of blowing up the planet
so it's important that people know that
the lies are being risked by this very
particular experiments there are like
less than 10 of those experiments
happening this year and the glitter says
that we should not do that before this
is like the informed decision yeah I I
want to get uh play some of the
statements from those insiders in a
second but I would like to ask you about
sort of the mechanics of the pause
you're calling for
what how how would that work uh ideally
what kind of what would be the sort of
coordinating mechanism and what are the
conditions that you would want to see
met before you take your finger off that
pause button in terms of training these
large language models that are at the
level of GPT for or above
I mean ideally uh there should be kind
of affirmative
cases made by people who are or
companies who are doing those uh
experiments that this will be safe and
I'm not saying that this is impossible
because like there are some invariants
that you can uh that you can ideally
prove about like what is doing the
pre-training phase uh what the llms are
capable of doing uh and and what they're
not because of some kind of technical
technical constraints uh that then
should be like externally monitored and
audited uh so um
uh but like how to do it how to do the
boss is very simple you just like uh
have U.S government to say that like no
such
big training runs until there there is
uh some external auditing and some
constraints in place
so by external auditing are you saying
that someone from the federal government
should come in and you know the federal
government needs to establish some sort
of guidelines and an agency to go in and
make sure they're meeting these
guidelines so this is actually like a
point where I have to say that like I am
kind of less informed and and less
knowledgeable about like what is kind of
uh
uh the most effective Ankara most
targeted intervention there I would like
kind of the companies themselves
together with some external
non-biased uh
stakeholders to work out what these
constraints should be and I know that
their companies again insiders are
worried and like at this point in
private discussions and they are kind of
actively working on various constraints
so I don't think some is being kind of
dishonest when he when he says that that
there is like some kind of external
ideal International uh body needed to to
constrain the experiments
before we start playing some of those
statements from those insiders I just
like to get Robin's reaction to that
idea that there is this anxiety within
the industry but because of the market
dynamics there's no way to stop it
absence the intervention of an external
Force like the government coming in and
auditing and making sure everyone's
playing Within These parameters
what seems to me the main issue we
should be discussing here is how
plausible is it that if they let GPT 5
do training in the Untamed mode then
there's a one percent chance of
destroying the world in that training
run because that just seems crazy high
and as an estimate for that particular
event I I see there's lots of concerns
where AI could eventually go and the
kinds of issues about that and I
definitely see that a lot of people in
the AI industry believe that it's going
to go a long way and that we should be
focusing on that and addressing that and
I I agree with that but I disagree with
the idea that the next training run
would somehow destroy the world that is
these things you know they just take
input and they give you output until you
hook them up as an agent in the world
that can do things they can't do things
and the usual feel people worried about
it somehow this thing will be so smart
that it will then figure out how to
improve itself but it doesn't have the
ability to improve itself unless you
give it those Powers so so the question
is why should we be worried that the
next training run will destroy the world
why not just talk about where this whole
thing could go and how we want to worry
about that and I'm happy like I said I
have some compromise policy
recommendations for how we should you
know in a mild way try to deal with some
of the bigger long-term problems but I I
just can't buy this short-term risk
story what are the scenarios that you're
worried about John I mean I know you can
go out there and read all sorts of
Doomsday scenarios but what are the ones
you know especially in the shorter term
that are most concerning to you that
you're trying to stop from happening
with this kind of pause
yeah so I have a kind of like two
um
uh two things that boring me first of
all like the Insiders who are training
them they are concerned and again when I
talk to them privately like I haven't
found anyone yet I'm sure like if I'm
gonna
kind of like do like more searching I
will find someone who will be dismissive
uh but but but so but so far like just
asking
asking their own people like yeah like
we can't can't say like can't be like
more confident than than less than one
percent of complete destruction uh so
and the other one is like the way it is
like llm uh training works is that you
have basically uh like I think modified
version of Linux uh that is uh running
those experiments
and and basically they're running on on
data centers that have like tens of
thousands of graphics cards I guess like
thousands of machines I don't actually
know what the ratio there is and the
Linux system is insecure uh there are uh
like bugs in there and we are training
the system to a
know very well that is a language model
know very well what Linux is know very
well uh what the uh
uh what its holes are and be a good
coder in fact like there are a tpt4
already you can give it a code and ask
it like what are the vulnerabilities
here uh so it's uh
like
in sort of like entrepreneurs morphizing
mode and all chat add to this uh data
centers are not really secure uh in my
understanding from going inside out like
the data centers are like the firewalls
the purpose of firewalls is used to
usually kind of protect Insight from the
from the rest of the internet uh but
like they're much less secure from going
uh from from inside out
so uh like at this point it's like it's
a bit like at the risk of like some
other entrepromorphic morphising uh but
not like insane outromorphizing like we
are uh training A system that basically
knows that is being a data centers it
probably knows where the data centers
are it pro it definitely knows how the
fight what the how the firewall Works in
fact like a couple of months ago I used
GPT 3.5 to configure my own firewall uh
at least get get advice how to do that
uh and uh
uh so so the so the worry is that that
like when we think that we are sort of
uh
okay let me add more one more thing like
during the training uh we are throwing
an internet at it the internet contains
uh data where where people ask or their
text or where the system is being asked
uh to break out the dude to take over
the world and whatnot because that's
what an inter contains a lot of a lot of
information like that so like the system
during training is constantly being put
in mode uh in kind of motivated uh to do
something to get out uh like
it probably can't because there are some
kind of constraints that still hold but
like God do these constraints hold uh
to the confidence of yeah less than one
percent uh system escaping or doing
something that that is like outside the
nominal parameters as to say
yeah not really
what what's your uh reaction to that
Robin
um the idea that you know even if the
the odds are are low one percent or you
know or you know some fraction of one
percent the fact that the we to go all
Rumsfeld there are known unknowns and
unknown unknowns and that there's
something fundamental to the nature of
this technology that eventually
something's going to happen and it's
going to leak out if we're not extremely
conscious starting now building these
these fire these impenetrable firewalls
I think we should identify the scenario
of most concern
and then add extra liability around that
that's my proposal for what I've called
fume liability because foom is the
scenario people are concerned about here
and the food this liabilities the
scenario people are most concerned about
are is an agent that is very smart as a
GPT 5 would be but in addition
sees itself as an agent with goals
uh able to take actions in the world
uh able to and inclined to improve
itself
and then
um you know find some way to improve
itself enormously over an enormous scope
in a very rapid period of time in ways
that the owners and monitors can't see
that's a conjunction of scenario of
assumptions together I find pretty
unlikely but I don't think policy should
really depend that much on my estimate
of the chance or on your estimates of
the chance fine if there's any sort of
chance let's set up a policy that's
robust
to the chance of the problem and that
would be basically if if some if one of
these systems causes harm the more of
these factors that are the risk factors
for this problem that are involved the
higher the liability would be we just
have an extra penalty
that would then discourage people away
from the most risky scenarios uh that
seems like a reasonable compromise
approach to me but these first systems
like just gpt5 trained doesn't have most
of those risky factors which is why I
find it very unlikely very unlikely that
gpt5 by itself trained would be the
problematic system that is the system
just takes you know queries and gives
responses it doesn't have goals it's not
you know planning actions in the world
that doesn't have power to do things in
the world it can't improve itself it
isn't even inclined to improve itself so
it's not going to be the problem but I
get that there's a scenario people are
worried about and even though I give
that a low probability I say fine let's
find a compromise where we can increase
liability liability is in fact one of
our most robust regulatory processes we
have in in our society rather than set a
government agency and rules I'd much
rather use law and liability to address
whatever concerns people have
and here's the a poll that you ran on
your Twitter uh about this question
let's uh our rhpr respect human property
rights equals respect human property
rights what is your biggest AI concern
super AI does not respect human property
rights and kills us most AIS are not uh
respecting human property rights and we
starve AIS respect uh human property
rights but take most jobs or D AIS
respect to human property rights but
many humans fail to ensure against AI
taking jobs in their half of your
followers said super AI kills us all uh
so uh what do you uh I'm gonna bring in
and so Robin is saying that this
scenario that people seem to be most
concerned about of self-improving AI
suddenly deciding we'd be better off as
something you know not humans just you
know a bunch of atoms to be used for
something else
that doesn't seem intrinsic to
the what chat GPT you know gpt4 or even
gbt5 is at all capable of is he missing
something in that analysis Jan yeah I
think it's just wrong uh the like first
of all like I do think that uh yeah film
Insurance awesome like uh like I think
uh
the reason why letter uh
gonna fast for just like let's stop uh
the giant experiments that are being
planned uh like was that like this was
this is like the simplest police
intervention uh like obviously like the
correct police intervention would be
something more complex but it's like
developing it and agreeing to it would
take much more time I definitely would
uh like cheer on various forms of
insurance or liability liability schemes
that are ideally commensurate uh with
the risk that people are taking so when
it comes to agents uh sort of agency of
GPT models there is this post called the
simulators unless wrong and I'm going to
cut it tldr R is that you should think
of
GPT
large language models a soup of agents
that you can kind of fish out agents or
like processes that are that are
potentially very urgently uh by
prompting so like if you ask give me a
dialogue between Steve Jobs and and
Plato it will basically that will kind
of like fish out like certain processes
uh in that
from that soup that tried to uh
try to mimic the real world processes
that we labeled Steve Jobs and Plato
and including I think including their
preferences including their co-direct
and tests including including interim
vision of course
there are only like sort of low
resolution approximations but like there
would be higher and higher
approximations as as the as the
technology improves and the more compute
we spend on on training those so yeah
agent agent Nets and coolness is only
only before the prompt moment we put put
a prompt that agent that comes comes out
and importantly the prompts are like the
way the system is trained is that it
will give given like a trillion prompts
uh or like at least billions of prompts
and that that's just that nature like
there is like no uh fundamental
difference between uh it being used uh
by people giving it prompts or or it
being trained during the training time
is being prompted and then like the
response is being checked against the
next token and then like it is uh kind
of back propagated uh based on what a
prediction was correct or not so like if
there is uh like a text or Plato on the
internet it will try to pretend to be
Plato during that training moment if
there is a text of like some Maniac
that's trust over the tries to take over
the Galaxy it will pretend to be a
maniac that tries to take over the
Galaxy
and uh
yeah and so okay the self-improvement
bit it's
correct that it is uh you know it is
hard for a system that is trained with
like lots of compute uh to self-improve
in a naive manner however it is very
possible uh it's very likely that for
human level
uh strategic operator being a to be a
human level strategic operator you don't
need to have like that much power
because humans have humans operate like
12 Watts rather than something like 10
megawatts or something like that so the
GPT is being trained but
so uh it's it's like one concern is that
it will just develop a kind of some kind
of new kind of AI that UMass just didn't
didn't figure out rather than kind of
try to self-improve in a more brute
force uh way and the final one is that
donors can't see well first of all yeah
they can't because like that that's how
the system current runs they're being
it's being left alone for months uh and
uh but but the second thing is like
sometimes the like owners seeing
something only matters if donors have a
plan to do something when they see
something they don't
so to the point about uh you know
developing some sort of unforeseen
capability uh that you know I want to
return for a second to the point that
Jan
raised earlier about
every Insider he's spoken to has
expressed some level of concern about
that being an issue they're not they
they're a little bit nervous or scared
by the fact that they're seeing things
that they they can't quite explain or
that they were not expecting to happen
um we had a commenter here who kind of
summarizes the position Chris Brown says
if a nuclear engineer says something is
dangerous
non-nuclear Engineers should respect
that opinion
um I'm going to play a we're going to
play a couple clips from some of these
insiders the first is going to be Sundar
pichai the CEO of Google who uh recently
had this to say
um on 60 Minutes about the state of AI
one of the things we need to be careful
when it comes to AI is avoid what I
would call Race conditions where people
working on it across companies Etc so
get caught up in who's first
that we lose you know the potential
pitfalls and downsides to it
and then we've also got a former uh
Google employee one of the
pioneers of the kind of AI research that
has led to the the emergence of these
models Jeffrey Hinton who uh resigned
from Google he says so that he could
speak a little more freely about the
risks that he sees I want to play a clip
from him as well on CNN talking to Jake
Tapper
I'm not an expert on hydrogen regulation
I'm just a scientist who suddenly
realize that these things are getting
smarter than us
um and I want to sort of blow the
whistle and say we should worry
seriously about how we stop these things
getting control over us
um and it's going to be very hard and I
don't have the solutions I wish I did
so the thing that worries me about this
a little bit Robin is that
I have witnessed a
pandemic that may have leaked from a
laboratory and I've seen the way that
scientists kind of close ranks to make
it difficult to even talk about that
possibility early on and so I guess I've
become a little more sensitive to this
idea of tail risk and
um when when you've got people that are
close to the problem saying or close to
the issue saying there's a problem it
does give me a little bit of pause does
to any of these recent statements sway
you
so or in the pause Direction
I see these statements as mainly
speaking to the risk of AI in the next
few decades and that we should be
addressing that and dealing with it and
I agree with that I let's see them
saying that the next GPT 5 run could
kill us all that's the thing I was
disagreeing with if say you make a GPT 5
it's not an agent by itself but I agree
that you can make an agent out of it and
as you say you could make billions of
different agents out of it but if
millions of different people make
millions of different agents out of GTP
5 then they may well get better and
smarter but they are in a world of lots
of other humans and systems and other
AIS so the scenario of concern seems to
be that one of these AIS somehow takes
over the world
so it has to not just out compete its
owners and Builders who are watching and
testing it it has to out compete the
entire rest of the world in terms of
military and police and monitoring and
it has to out-compete all the other AIS
made out of GT5 all the other agents if
if you release gpt5 and many people can
make agents out of it and they do they
will each one of them will be trying to
control their thing it might get out of
control but one person letting their
agent get out of control of them doesn't
destroy the world so the the the
scenario whereby and out of control AI
destroys the world is a very different
sort of concern than and out of control
AI might you know deplete your bank
account or you know destroy some system
that it that it could get access to or
things like that I think there's a lot
of reasons to think about you know
powerful AIS and what they can do and
how to manage a world with them I'm just
being skeptical about the scenario that
the next time we run gtv5 by itself
which isn't even an age and it's going
to destroy the world let's go past that
and ask what other scenarios get bad how
fast and what we can do about that
that Prospect of lots of different AIS
out there sort of vying for power or
dominance uh is an interesting and kind
of scary in some ways uh thing to think
about but uh it does you know make me
think about in terms of the pause
is this even really
like meaningful at this point is is the
cat kind of out of the bag uh there was
this memo that leaked from Google
um that oh sorry this is the wrong slide
uh
um from one of uh the senior software
Engineers within Google and what it
seemed to be saying is that well here
I'll just read a little bit of the note
the uncomfortable truth is we aren't
positioned to win this arms race and
neither is open Ai and what this memo
author is saying is that
Google's competitor is not really open
AI or any other firm but actually open
source models so
they've been people have been training
you know meta's training data I guess
leaked out and open source Engineers
have been uh creating AIS on that data
that seem to at least according to this
author uh be catching up to what openai
and Google are doing he says they're
doing things with a hundred dollars and
13 billion parameters that we struggle
with at 10 million and 540 billion
dollars first of all Jan
um how much Credence do you give that
that you know the open source movement
is going to kind of catch up or maybe
even lap the big centralized firms and
if that's true does it change the way
you think about
what can be done to
rain or to to create safety rails around
existing AI
yeah I mean it's it's uh I mean I don't
know it's like simple answer like more
more complex answer is that like to
think that pulls uh
achieves again pause on like pushing the
frontier in terms of those Lodge
soon to be multi-billion dollar uh AI
summoning experiments like one thing it
achieves again I I said that like you
you will get like lots of Agents during
the training run itself and like so you
have risk of self-deployment
self-deployment the way you deploy an AI
is a series of computer computer
programs sorry series of computer
commands uh that are sent to the data
center uh they are in the data centers
perfectly capable of sending sending
those uh commands so so the question is
like oh there what kind of prevent what
kind of like firewalls Etc are in place
to make sure that it like uh it can't
self-deploy
uh but but yeah so uh but one thing that
uh pause achieves is that we will not
push the uh Frontier in terms of like
risky uh pre-training experiments the
other thing it achievement achieves is
that the open source uh until we can
work at large uh has been working on has
been
working from the
from the kind of biggest uh open source
available uh pre-trained system that I
think for a while and perhaps still it
was the Facebook llama that they trained
and in my opinion like completely
responsibly just dumped on the world
uh so uh so like the open source
certainly currently does not have the
ability to travel like hundreds of
millions of dollars or again soon to be
billions billions at these large AI
summoning experiments it can kind of
take already pre-trained AIS and then
customize and optimize them and I think
that is where
uh I think kind of Robin's insights are
much more
uh valuable uh because I as a method of
General I think like our main difference
with Robin is that like I I work from
like inside uh so like inside view I see
like what what's happening on the on the
low level and then I think about what
are the
uh one of the interesting properties
that might kind of have unexpected
effect on the world uh and that thing
has served me indeed like super well in
my life in general and uh but and
Robinson is kind of like outside view
taking like looking at the world in
general in identifying inter interesting
patterns and think of distilling them
down into into different contexts for
example insiders might miss them
with uh
um I want to return for a second to the
the quote from Jeffrey Hinton about this
worry that you know he expresses a worry
that they're going to suddenly or are
suddenly becoming smarter than us than
than humans
um and uh it there was this interesting
the conversation that was well before I
get into that conversation
what do you think is the substance of
his worry there like what does he mean
when he's saying that it will suddenly
surpass human intelligence is that
something that
I mean what do you think is causing him
to have that concern Beyond
oh I mean that's kind of question to
Jeff intern exactly but if you ask me
there is this concept called or this
phenomenon called crocking again you can
search you can you can find a paper by
Neil Nanda a researcher deepmind
uh
where you're gonna when you train a
large language model uh to the so-called
kind of loss function its ability to
predict the next token kind of tends to
go smoothly down however various
capabilities uh that are sort of like
stream of that prediction
um
predicting the next token ability they
tend to go through like phase shifts so
for example ability to do uh
arithmetic like in the beginning like it
just can't do it and then like if you uh
if if you like as a function of this
less loss function the ability to do
arithmetic uh does not go does not grow
kind of smoothly it tends to go like uh
a little bit and then just like phase
transition kind of it Crocs uh the
croaking is like a hacker term uh about
like truly understanding and need Lander
has done a work but where he has
actually looked under the hood of the
network and found that indeed uh the
system develops some kind of weird
organic looking but precise function for
the thing that it is being asked to us
to do and this function basically needs
enough examples at which point it kind
of coalesces and and we will see like a
sudden jumping capability so so that's
like a sort of
sort of mechanistic reason to expect
sudden jumps in capabilities because
they they're just the nature of elements
does yeah yeah go ahead Robin
so what he's talking about are jumps and
capabilities in relatively local scopes
of tasks
so the question is how plausible is it
that the entire system's capability will
jump overall by a large amount that's
much less plausible just given the fact
that sometimes you grok a particular
thing
uh I want to notice that basically in
our world the smartest people don't take
over the world consistently we we do
have super intelligent creatures our
corporations and Nations and
organizations and they are in fact much
more smart than any individual but we
tame them largely through law and
competition and so the the scenario
people are worried about isn't just
something being smart you have to add a
bunch of other things to the worrisome
scenario it has to have some unusual
abilities in some particular area and
then it has to have very different
preferences than it you know its
Builders intended and then it's you know
it has to be able to take advantage of
some unusual opportunity and unusual
preferences to greatly improve its
position those are the scenarios of
concern which I find relatively unlikely
but I'm happy to develop some liability
approaches to deal with but you know
just notice generically things being
smarter in particular tasks isn't a big
problem in the world today
what how was how would the liability
work to protect against this sort of
risk if the risk that some of the most
AI worried people are expressing is
basically total Destruction because if
that happens then liabilities
meaningless right so what it how does
the liability function in in this world
right so the idea is that when you're
being risky and Taking Chances
uh if there's identifiable elements of
the riskiness of the chance you're
taking most of the things that would be
risky aren't going to destroy the world
but they are going to be closer or
farther from this scenario of concern so
basically sometimes people will use an
AI sloppily and then it will cause
damage to somebody else and then we ask
how many of these problematic elements
did that scenario involve and we'd
penalize you more the more of those
problematic elements were involved so
that you knew ahead of time you should
just stay away from certain parts of
this space of possibilities because if
if you do something and it causes a
problem you have to pay a lot more there
so it's just a general way of pushing
people away from the problematic corner
of the parameter space which as I said
before as involves a whole bunch of
things that have to go wrong together to
make the bad thing happen uh and so yes
if the worst thing happens you can't
penalize them then but most of the times
when people do things near the worst
thing uh it won't destroy the world
world you could penalize them a lot and
then you could discourage them that way
by the way I would combine this with
some sort of required liability
insurance that would even strengthen it
such that
the bigger the damages and the more they
have to make sure somebody some
insurance company is set up to pay for
it and that would also discourage them
in the sense that it would be harder to
arrange for that insurance and the
insurers would say you know you know
show me that you're not going too close
to this problematic part and they have
problem doing that and that's why they
would stay away that's the idea and to
to return to your Poll for a second here
it's it's interesting that you frame it
in terms of respecting human property
rights is that how when we talk about
things like AI alignment so trying to
make sure that
artificial intelligence is aligned with
human goals and human Prosperity is that
your way of thinking about it that
respecting human property rights is more
or less like the I don't know moral or
ethical framework that designers should
be aiming for
I would say in our world today the main
way that we try to decide who we can
trust and be near isn't so much checking
that they share our values it's checking
that they are Law Abiding and in some
sort of reasonable legal regime
including respect for property rights so
I would say that's what you should more
worry about for AIS is that they won't
respect property rights they may steal
or have a revolution or things like that
you should you know the reason why you
might be worried about their values is
because you think it might induce that
sort of an event so that's the more
fundamental problem AIS that do respect
property rights I mean there are
concerns people have but that's more
like okay they allow competes in the
long run they'll get more wealth they
will sort of drift more to senders of
control and power and even if there's
peace and prosperity many people don't
like the scenario where AI is just
slowly peacefully displace us and we
could talk about what to do about that
and I think there's other robust
policies to to consider there including
robots took your job insurance
um but again you know if you're worried
about that we could talk about that but
if you're worried about the AI suddenly
taking over and killing everyone then
you're talking about some violation
property rates right
to say the least yes
um so I want to play just a snippet from
this this conversation actually I don't
agree but
please John if you have disagreement
jump in so like one concern like one
potential problem I can see is that the
AI suddenly quickly changing I mean
particular scenario so it's unlikely but
like that said like evacuating the
atmosphere is that like violation of
property rights yeah pretty much I think
so okay I mean if you sue somebody in a
court of law for taking the atmosphere
over your property I think you'd win the
lawsuit I think that would be considered
a reasonable tort look at our concept of
the law
that yes all right then then that that
the need would have been property right
if you efficient so the one of the uh
most
vociferous and prominent AI concern CR
uh people out there has been uh Eliezer
Eleazar uh yodowsky uh yankowski and um
he writes here that pausing AI
developments isn't enough we need to
shut it all down
um and that the key issue is not human
competitive intelligence is the open
letter puts it but the more likely
result of building a super humanly smart
AI
um and that you know the AI does not
love you it does not hate you uh and uh
nor does it hate you and you're made of
atoms it can use for something else that
that's kind of the fundamental problem
and that you know uh a pause
is really not sufficient what what did
you make of his reaction to the open
letter Jan
um
I mean is the person who's going to cut
me into this uh you know
yeah I risk in the first place in in
like 2008 2009 so I have like tremendous
respect for him and I think he's just
right in the limit uh like once we
indeed have superintelligence and again
I give
I can't rule out that GPT 5 will be
super intelligent in that way
like 10 we have like a lot of problems
like we are not bound by like pheromones
in ant hills uh or like the rules of
tantail just like I I just don't see how
how like superhuman AI would be bound by
the rules of human economy
um
but like of course I'm just I'm trying
to understand the the disconnect here
between you and Robin on the likelihood
of chat GB of GPT 5 becoming super
intelligent you are saying that you
think that's you can't rule it out Robin
is saying that's
almost certainly not going to happen
what do you think is the substance of
that
disagreement
just a question to me uh sure I mean
whoever yeah I mean what is there
anything you've been hearing from Robin
yeah I mean yeah
I would just like point to TPT to GPT
free gpt4 and the fact that like GPT 4
already uh like I think AES in general
in the last few years have been knocking
down various kind of benchmarks uh
faster than can then we can come up with
them so it's kind of
I would say it's almost strange uh to be
confident like confident as in like less
than one percent the GPT 5 would not be
significant to superhuman I mean gp4 is
already sort of like like 90th
percentile uh college student in in many
domains
so I'm granting that GPT 5 could be
superhuman on many performance
characteristics what I'm doubting is
that that destroys the world that is we
have to construct a scenario after you
have very smart gpt5 such that the world
gets destroyed and that's the path where
I'm I'm skeptical I I see you would use
it many people would use it many people
that have access to a somewhat
superhuman uh capability many people
would use it for contrary purposes uh
police would use it military would use
it all the people defending us against
theft and destruction would also be
using it we would all be increasing our
capabilities with superhuman AI but that
doesn't directly destroy the world
yeah I
I think like as I said the layers is I
think right in the limit they're really
kind of like question is like what
happens between now and the limit and I
think they're possibly kind of the laws
of economy might kind of play like some
kind of shaping role but also possibly
not like again if the system gonna
self-deploy out of uh out of while being
just trained without any uh kind of
interaction with the economy in a way
that
makers intended then like a desert might
be more right than wrong
is there a point Robin where you would
suddenly become concerned and want to
start signing on to the open letter like
what what are you looking for that is
going to raise the alarm for you
well certainly if people were trying to
make the worst case systems and like the
management and funding of a particular
you know most advanced projects were
trying to make the worst case scenarios
they went out of their way to make those
scenarios well then I get a lot more
worried about those parents I think
they're a priori less likely and I want
to discourage them through some sort of
liability so people would only
accidentally produce the worst case
scenarios let's push them away from that
but obviously if you show me somebody's
going out of their way to make it then
I'm going to say hey
what about what about this argument that
some of these advances have been very
surprising there's a black box element
to neural networks and machine learning
where these advancements can be made
totally unexpectedly and that there's
potential for a Quantum Leap and it's
better to act now than after that
happens
we're going to see Quantum leaps and
particular abilities robustly as Jan
mentioned often you just rock something
and you get a local advancement and we
could have systems that are just just
generally getting better steadily but
the the question is how does that kill
the world I can see long term where AIS
take more of the economy they take more
positions of power they slowly have more
influence and then the world drifts in
their Direction and if they drift in
various directions you might worry about
that that's completely what we should be
talking about
and I can see humans might lose most of
their jobs in a relatively short period
say less than 10 years and we should set
up insurance for that uh I mean I think
there are these more likely scenarios
and sort of robust Solutions in a
situation like this you like you're
focusing on where we disagree but I
think we should try to focus more on
where we agree and what things we can
agree would be a good idea
could you tell me a little bit more
about those immediate concerns upon
which you agree and flesh out the idea
of the disruptions to the economy and
how you think those could be mitigated
well so I would say the most robust fear
people have always had about AI going
back centuries really is that humans
would lose their jobs
that the eye would just out-compete the
humans and most people today don't
actually own much wealth besides their
ability to work so if they suddenly
unexpectedly lose their ability to work
they don't have much other assets to go
back on and you know it's everybody's
long been worried about that and that's
what to do many people say Well what
we'll just do is have governments do a
Ubi then they'll just hand out lots of
money but the problem is the new AI
economy may be very unequally
distributed in the world
you're going to tax your local tax base
to pay for a Ubi to cover your local
workers out of work you may not have
much of a tax-based attacks that may not
work so what you need is something more
like global insurance through
reinsurance but you don't need this
insurance to be very specific to any
individual you don't have to do
underwriting for a person you can just
create basically a trigger event I.E say
you know within a five-year period say a
little labor force participation Falls
from above 50 to below 20 percent some
drastic fall in the number of people
working in a short time that could just
be the world trigger event and then
everybody who has a certain asset uh
that's set up of that just gets paid an
annuity of that asset we can just create
that asset and the people who buy the
opposite side of that asset I.E you know
get money if that doesn't happen they're
basically the people selling the
insurance the people who buy this asset
of people buying the insurance and we
can just set up a situation where the
people most at risk we say buy this
asset it wouldn't cost that much when
we're well away from the problem and the
Chance is low it's a cheap asset to buy
so we should just set up an asset and
basically recommend people get it maybe
get their employers to give it to them
maybe get their governments to give it
to them but the key point it needs to be
an asset based on a global asset base
not a local tax base so that people
could be assured that in the case of the
problem they get paid
are you in agreement on that yawn that
the that you know massive job
displacement is likely in the near
future and that
I mean what do you think of Robin's
proposal there
yeah I have like a few notes uh that I
got uh first I want to mention uh like
there is sort of uh
uh
one thing to uh say is that like the
pre-training phase is uh unsupervised
there is like just no place to kind of
correlate uh it the
the sugar that is being trained its
preferences with uh with uh the
preferences of the of the builders so
like that happens after uh the AI has
been summoned and this is being kind of
fine-tuned
there is like indeed like super
unresolved question uh in uh in grapheya
alignment Community which is like how
hard is coordination as a function of
intelligence and and I have uncertainty
about it the other things is Trivial
many people point out that like you can
construct games that uh where like
intelligence just will not help you uh
so so it's it's like a kind of fertile
area to research
uh then uh
when it comes to kind of agreements
disagreements yeah I think it's
important to kind of keep in mind that
like to think that I'm like arguing here
for is basically being
conscious of the tail risk uh and and
making sure that like we have some
guarantees that the pre-training uh like
the massive pre-trained experiments are
not going to destroy the uh destroy the
world and like this guarantees are
probably possible uh but the problem is
that the companies currently are not
incentivized to come up with those those
guarantees
and uh there was one thing one more
thing I wanted to mention oh yeah like
when Robin said that uh
like he would be worried if people would
be on deliberately and try to create
like worst uh worst case scenarios make
AI that you destroy the world
deliberately well
open source uh that's how like if you
it's not hard to find or the existing
projects uh that try to use uh open uh
Source uh AIS to maximize the damage I
mean that they are not that competitive
that competent yet so I take off like a
more sort of fun and games project at
this point but
this is just like uh early uh 2012. how
would you even regulate open source
development of these products I mean
that that kind of seems to undercut the
entire idea of there's even much you
could do about it
yeah so like I mean we already have uh
you know penalties for developing
viruses and stuff like that so it's it's
a like uh something probably could be uh
develop some kind of liability uh it can
be assigned uh from there but but I I
agree this is like super super much more
harder than just like making sure that
they're not going to summon even your
more competent minds and and release
them uh on the public but but yeah so
like My worry is mostly the tail risks
and when it comes to
got more mundane risks once we are
handled uh the situation that
uh spinning out of control completely uh
then uh yeah I think kind of Robin's
expertise and and people become more
traditional technology regulatory uh
expertise their their competence would
be great help so here's a another
compromise solution I know people who
work on secure operating systems who say
that you can provably uh show that some
operating systems are completely secure
and maybe you could just require they
use those operating systems for the
uh 200 lines of code here that would be
a relatively low cost honestly
and it would actually help kick start
this secure operating system world and
that seems like a reasonable regulation
that would be relatively low cost uh
addresses your most direct concern here
again I'm looking for compromises I'm
looking for things we can agree on yep
like 100 agreed and it's like including
kind of increasing the data center
Security on security of this uh
information security making sure that
the weights don't leak make sure that
the system is not capable of getting out
self-deployed to self-deploy itself uh
like just this has seem to be like
fairly low hanging proofs but really
importantly the companies are currently
racing and they are not motivated to
take any of those steps
the danger here is if we Empower some
regulatory body to do stuff it won't
just want to do a few best things it'll
have a big public behind it and they
want to you know take make speeches and
show how concerned they are and just do
a lot of extra too much stuff so uh we
want maybe even if we authorize some
regulation to make it limited and that's
part of the problem here the regulation
isn't often limited yeah yeah like I I I
agree with that like the of course the
problem is that the world is on a
deadline now so it's like the the
scaling Next Generation scaling will
start pretty much uh imminently and uh
uh and like The Regulators just will not
do any imminent actions unless like
pressured
what about the argument that to that
point of the way that you know over
regulation or or creating an entire
apparatus to do this could slow things
down to a degree that we know there's
other countries that are investing a lot
of money into AI some of them are
geopolitical Rivals to the United States
notably China uh right now U.S companies
seem to have an advantage
isn't there just an argument that
slowing down that advantage in any way
is itself dangerous
I I think it's important to stress that
the current AI Paradigm produce
uncontrollable Minds like the reason why
why baido uh
recorded pre-recorded all the
demonstration is that they uh I mean I
don't know exactly but I can speculate
that they were just afraid of the mind
uh saying things that would get attacked
their their CEO disappeared so it's uh
like I don't see like China being super
keen on on producing those
uncontrollable minds and and neither
should should be the west but yes
ultimately as we get like better in
controlling uh the AIS
um at least superficially so uh to to
not be any political danger and that's
the hardware companies are producing and
make it easier and easier uh to produce
these superhuman Minds uh we definitely
I don't think anything else than
International some kind of international
regulation uh that we have with uh
things like like nuclear materials Etc
uh short of that would help
I'd actually say that in the last
century we've seen a huge shift to from
a world that once had competing Nations
where the elites of each nations were
primarily loyal to that Nation to a
world where Elites around the world are
primarily loyal to a community of Elites
around the world that's caused a great
deal of convergence of regulation in
many areas even without International
governance bodies or rules and we could
count on a lot like that continuing so
basically even China craves
International respect in most regulatory
areas they mostly go along with
International standards of what
everybody else does so that they can
look like reasonable people in those
forms and I think if you ask for small
things for AI risk like using secure
operating systems for controlling runs
or something and that was the standard
practice that our regulations required
they would probably if they saw it as a
low cost wanting to go along with
conventions they would probably go along
with that I think that's actually a
reasonable Prospect
shut down the whole thing they're not
going to do that
I mean that's that's a great point that
uh like if as we solve it like cool with
reactions like they're like like a
surprising uniform
um I mean like what's like Sweden and
the rest of the world pretty much
uh you know if
I I want to uh bring a little bit I want
to bring up uh Robin's uh book that we
mentioned near the top the age of M uh I
think I've got the cover here
um and uh let's see
there we go and
um
you had this so uh this is like a
prolonged thought experiment about where
AI could go and by an M you mean a
an emulated brain so someone uh to
create the AI they've literally used
technology to scan the human brain and
then create a kind of Consciousness out
of that I've pulled an excerpt from a
TED Talk that you gave on it that I'm
going to play here in just a second Adam
if you could cue that up for us and then
ask you how you're feeling about the
prospects for the age of M at this point
someday
we may have robots the smartest people
artificial intelligence AI how could
that happen
one route is that we'll just keep
accumulating better software like we've
been doing for 70 years
at past rates of progress that may take
centuries
some Say it'll happen a lot faster as we
discover brand new powerful Theories of
Intelligence
I'm skeptical
but a third scenario
it's what I'm going to talk about today
the idea is to Port the software from
the human brain
um so do you
you know is that given what we've seen
unfold over the past year or so with
regards to the large language models
chat gbt
do you think that brain emulations are
still a likely scenario uh in the future
um or or have you changed your mind
so first even if we get General AGI soon
if it doesn't take over all the human
jobs it maybe takes over 70 percent of
previous human jobs then we would still
when we are able to make random
relations we would want to make them and
then the Iranian relations would still
do the remaining jobs and the hmm
scenario would play out roughly as
described so the main way in which
you know that's not our won't play out
would be if AI takes you know 99.9 of
the jobs I.E there's just no place left
for brain emulations uh however I'm just
not actually that convinced we're going
to get AGI that fast
so um you know I I get that the current
moment is people are really you know
enthused and excited but I have to
remind everybody which older people
should remember that basically every
decade or two or three for the last
century
we've had a burst of concern and
interest in automation we have some new
demos or Technologies and people say oh
my God like machines might take over
everything soon
and we've always had like a substantial
minority of people say that's a real
Prospect now we need to take deal with
that like in the 1960s there was a
presidential commission on that
about that and big you know top news
headlines about it and again in the
1980s I left grad school in physics and
philosophy to go off to find my future
in AI because I heard it was almost
going to be too late I was going to take
over everything soon that's what I did
in the early in the mid 1980s
and this just happens over and over so
we just seem to be really bad at looking
at current Technologies and saying how
close is it to doing all the jobs I
still think we're a ways away I the most
likely scenario I think is that it's
just going to be many more decades maybe
a lot of more decades till we actually
get AI that can do most human jobs I
mean so the really impressive thing
about the recent generation is they
basically do pretty well at the kind of
things we have college students do
they can replace college students and
college colleges are big like filter
that we say on who can be Elites in our
world so that's pretty crushing to our
pride
they can they can pass as a college
student pretty well but you know we
don't actually have most jobs being done
like college student skills right so the
big question is to what extent will
these AIS actually be able to do most of
the other tasks we have done in the
economy and I'm my bet is at least many
more decades before that happens which
gives more time for M's to show up
John do you think that maybe there's a
little bit of hype going on at the
moment that we are really decades at
least away from something approaching
artificial general intelligence which as
Robin puts it would be able to take away
most human jobs
and it doesn't look like that to me
however of course I can't be sure like
correctly like the Ella lamps just seem
to
respond by becoming more intelligent
well if you if you pull in put in more
more compute Cycles uh so they're they
they haven't saturated yet uh and people
plan to put in like a lot more compute
Cycles now
um unless they are being forced not to
uh of course it's possible that they
will saturate at one point uh like I
think we have something like uh six
orders of magnitude left
which in like six uh so it's like one
million times uh more powerful than gpt4
I think this planet can still train uh
plausibly uh given diagram of the hunger
to throw more money at it and the
hardware advances that are on the
horizon
uh but after that yeah you would need
kind of like the entire planet to put
like significant portion of the global
GDP uh into those training runs which
hopefully will not not happen so yeah
it's definitely possible that this
Paradigm will saturate uh I don't think
it's likely
how would we know that this thing called
artificial general intelligence has been
this condition has been met would it
just be obvious or is there some
indicator that that tells us
well I
it read about it's a matter of
definition right I mean I'm sure like
you can come up with a definition that
gpt4 like easily passes already uh it's
certain like very general compared to
like previous AI yeah paradigms uh but
like if we are talking about things that
is able to do AI research better than
better than humans uh then of course
that would be
um
potentially manifested by the fact that
we're dead
um yeah I mean what what's are what
definition Robin are you looking at to
to you know make your
prediction that this is several decades
out what what do you expect is still or
what are you saying is still pretty far
out of reach in terms of capabilities
well the key definition we all care
about is what fraction of human jobs do
they actually do
right and you know that test of that is
how fast do we actually displace humans
with those tests and for-profit
companies are quite eager to do that
replacement as soon as they can so uh
the there's not they're not holding back
per se
it's just hard to you know actually
automate many particular tasks and you
know that's the main parameter I'll be
looking at in the next decade is how
what fraction of job tasks are in fact
displaced
and basically how fast does the world
economy grow
I mean those are the key parameters
we're interested in and that's what we
should be tracking and at the moment
those needles haven't moved very much
but of course it's only been a few
months so let's watch those needles I
mean this kind of illustrates kind of
hard difference how Robin goes from like
outside in like from inside out because
the thing that I would be tracking is
like how much uh in every successful
every success every generation uh
how much
effort was kind of
put in input by uh humans on how much
was AI because it's already non-zero by
AI
when it comes to like designing the
chips and architectures
there's one more topic I want to hit on
before we close out this stream but I
did want to ask Jan about this phrase
that you've brought up a couple of times
of uncontrollable Minds um you say that
uncontrollable Minds have been created
could you just explain that phrase a
little bit more what do you mean by that
so one way of explaining it is that uh
the minds are gonna still controllable
like we are creating more and more
powerful like smarter and smarter
machines while using the fact that they
are dumb to control them so like this
thing kind of like last on go on forever
and I think a laser has correct a laser
Kowski has correctly pointed out that
the big problem with like all the AI
paradigms pretty much uh currently is
that we don't know okay correction all
AI paradigms that rely on back
propagation a gradient descent where you
basically have this kind of a black box
that we train to perform a function like
all their problems like they all have
this problem that they we they are
researchers actually do not know how to
reliably uh Point uh this black box to
like any gold
just like
Evolution uh who had like a perfectly
clear uh goal uh it did not know how to
point uh humans at that call we did not
become kind of self-replication
maximizers which we are just like a uh
soup of heuristics that work in in
ancestral environment but not so much uh
once we are kind of smarter
how much do you think about the question
of sentience or Consciousness in that
regard is that something that you're
worried about
emerging spontaneously in a way that we
cannot predict so I don't know my
I I kind of observe that people are
often confused by mixing up
Consciousness and competence I think
it's no reason to mix them up we in fact
we don't know like any uh
task where competence in it requires you
to be conscious perhaps writing about
Consciousness or something like that I
guess you can probably write about
Consciousness without being conscious so
like by default I expect the machines
that kill us be not conscious but I I am
very uncertain about it it's it's of
course possible that they will be
conscious
and what about you uh Robin do you have
any thoughts on Consciousness emerging
obviously if we have brain emulations
they will be conscious but emerging
through other routes
um when
um
how do you think about that
my guess is consciousness is a
relatively robust feature of large
complicated mental systems that have
self-awareness and some self model but
I'm more interested in the previous
discussion of Minds out of control okay
I want to point out that the old Soviet
Union was really obsessed with making
sure it controlled its citizens in all
its organizations and had spies
everywhere and you know all sorts of
things to like make sure they never
deviated from their you know official
agenda that didn't go very well very
well and our world of say the United
States and the West we do not keep peace
by making sure everybody has control
fully controlled values
and you know I'll make sure we agree
with us on everything we allow big
organizations and groups of people to
have quite varied values as long as they
keep the peace in terms of respecting
the law uh so that's what I would say is
like you know if you want to say we
don't know how to make an AI respect the
law or obey
uh social norms that might be the more
the criticism saying we don't know how
to make an AI that is fully enslaved and
will always do exactly what we would
have wanted even if we aren't around
that just seems the wrong standard to be
thinking in terms of
I mean so many things to say there but
like yes if it could make AI to obey the
Norms in a way that it just wouldn't
exploit lots of loopholes uh big enough
but that's why follow it up just by
letter humans are also able to exploit
noise and exploit loopholes and our
world persists even in the face of that
most for-profit firms would be happy to
exploit loopholes and violate in arms if
they could get away with it the reason
they don't is because they can't get
away with it not because they're not
very capable
they're really capable or you know
Walmart Google they're they're large
organizations
there are lots of norms in ant hill
who cares
okay we're not talking about not to
bring those norms
uh you uh so I what if I hear what
you're saying correctly on you're saying
that the the Norms are not gonna matter
because or or the laws even because the
uh super intelligence AI or even a just
very intelligent AI will be able to
fairly easily evade any of these
restrictions yes unless there's some
kind of like Dynamic uh that kind of
imprints the respect for laws as it as
it gets more powerful and potential
itself improves which like I'm super
interested in Arguments for but I
haven't heard any kind of like this the
obvious Dynamic is a world of millions
of AIS who have to keep the peace with
each other any one of which can't take
over the world because they face the
obstacle and opposition of all the other
AIS who don't want the one AI to kill
them all and take over the world so as
AIS together get better then they would
have to have some system to keep the
peace among themselves law law is such a
system and it probably would be the
system they would use to keep the pieces
of human law again like we don't we
don't kind of like share our legislative
practices with chimpanzees but they
would start out in our world initially
AIS would be in our world obeying our
laws and they would be initially
imprinted and trained to you know be in
our world obeying our laws and it's only
over time as they became a large
fraction of the world that the world's
laws would now evolve in their Direction
but now we're well past these early
years we're we're well into the you know
scenario I said sorry to be concerned
about what happens when AIS dominate the
world just because they become totally
more productive and and wealthy
yeah I think it's sort of
plausible uh but again this is like
going from outside in and like looking
at at like these actual servers uh that
are humming I'm kind of like having
hard time to cross the cup like how how
this could be kind of like parts and
like participants in human uh
lucky let me take that take that back
it's just that kind of see that there is
some kind of cap uh between the what's
happening on a metal level and and
what's happening on the on the social
social level uh it it's possible that it
will be crossed but I I
I have a lot of uncertainty there
let's close out the stream with a little
bit of optimism because uh it really is
it's incredible technology that we're
seeing where we're living through some
pretty exciting changes right now
um let's imagine a world where things go
roughly how each of you would like to
see them go and we'll start with Yan if
if AI progresses in a safe and
productive way what are some of the
things that you are most excited about
over the next five years to a decade
I mean there are a lot of ways how this
planet is sub-optimal people are
suffering just like a thousand
kilometers where I'm sitting there are
explosions going off uh and uh and like
people are dying up old age which like
if you ask them they would always like
to like almost always want to live like
one more day uh so like these are
clearly things that additional
intelligence is kind of well managed uh
uh could help help a lot but in general
I don't
I don't think that much about the good
Futures uh I I think about kind of
properties that I would like them like
those uh Futures to have for example I
want them to be a lot of fun like fun is
something that is kind of
introspectively available to people and
they they know when when they're having
fun and when they're when they're not
having fun and also like things like
you know optionality ability to choose
and not be cursed uh and uh and things
like kind of
a lot of fairness in the form of
roles in a veil of ignorance you should
be both you should be able to think uh
for between different or choosing
between different Futures without
knowing who exactly you will be there
and kind of thereby achieving like a
kind of
good future for all
and Robin if the government and various
Regulators around the world fail to
crush Ai and its infancy what is what
are the prospects about an AI
future an AI dominated future let's say
that most excite you
well so over the last few decades we've
seen many new exciting Technologies
appear
compared to those this is more exciting
because it seems to have more tensile
but it's also in some sense more
democratic that is most of the people
figuring out what this can do are just
people trying it themselves they don't
need to get a big startup and lots of
funding they just start using this in
their ordinary business life and see
what can happen and that's really
exciting because if a lot of them find a
lot of useful applications we're just
going to get this big wave of
productivity where a lot of people
figure out a lot of ways to do things
better
and that will not only make us all
richer and healthier but it will make
more of a sense that we should be
expecting and wanting Innovation and
change and Technology to spread and more
of an optimism that the future could be
better because of that and more of a an
eagerness to maybe instead of looking
for all the things that could go wrong
and trying to fix them that we should be
looking for all the things that go right
and how to encourage them and that
sounds like an exciting future over the
next decade is a world gets more
optimistic and excited because great
stuff is happening and they're more
interested in pursuing new options than
in closing them off and then complaining
about why things aren't better
that that would be wonderful to at the
very least cut down on the constant
complaining but I I can't complain at
all about this stream this was extremely
enlightening I appreciate both of you
taking the time to talk through this
really important issue Robin Hansen Jan
talin thank you for joining me today
thanks for everyone who tuned in and and
watched the stream and is listening by a
podcast we will be back here next week
same time Thursday 1 p.m we will see you
then thanks